the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody we're here at the 2022
summer chess classic addison lewis just
club we have two great round-robin
tournaments for you to bring you all of
the action i am grandmaster alejandro
ramirez here with my good friend
grandmaster christian carrillo alejandro
always a pleasure to be here in studio
be with you casting the games of the
best chess players we have here on soil
in saint louis now talk to us about
these two tournaments what do they mean
for the saint louis chess club and for
these players i have to say this has a
personal meaning to me this is a great
project
we have a void in the chess world
tournaments that really exemplify going
from open events really strong 2500s to
the elite there's 2 600 grand master
tournaments these round robin events
they're very rare and i love having the
summer classics here
the classic series is a great place for
tournaments for players that are very
talented to really reach their potential
a great opportunity indeed and let's
actually take a look at the standings in
group a yu yang yi is leading with four
points tied for second position we have
jonas bier abhimanyu misra and benjamin
gledura with three and a half points a
piece tied for fifth position we have
sam savion who unfortunately lost a
tremendous game against the more
experienced ilya smirin he's tied with
aram hakobian for the fifth position
tied for seventh we have nico theodore
grigori oparin and elias miriam and what
do we have in the b group alejandro uh
we have a very tight pack but actually
jj ali miranda is currently sitting
first place on four and a half points
with guillermo vazquez the difference is
that jj alimoran is actually facing
brandon jacobson today
and unfortunately for the tournament
brandon jacobson had to withdraw due to
illness we don't know if it's covered
but uh we don't think it is but there
are other illnesses in the world and he
then felt that he'd fall sick
had to withdraw from the event and all
the players that he has faced so far
they will retain their score against him
but because he withdrew past the 50 mark
uh all the players that he will face
since then will receive a full point by
including jj today so guillermo vazquez
actually needs a win to keep up uh with
the turkish player
absolutely and let's take a look at the
format of these two events we have two
ten player round robins unfortunately
both of the events are down to nine
players ray robson unfortunately tested
positive for akovid and as you were
mentioning alejandro brandon jacobson
had to withdraw as well 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves 30 minutes for the
rest of the game also the players are
getting a 30 second increment starting
from move one and how about the schedule
of the huddle well the schedule's pretty
simple we have two rounds left i'm not
really sure why it says uh all three of
them but uh today is thursday june 9th
which means that we are playing round
eight right now at 1 pm and tomorrow
because we have the potential of
playoffs remember that this tournament
it's not determined by mathematical pool
calls or sonoma burger or anything like
that we're straight up going into a
playoff played on the board at 5 p.m to
accommodate that we will be starting two
hours earlier tomorrow both the
game and the commentary the commentary
will start at 1 30 p.m to join us then
to determine the winner of the summer
chess classic uh if necessary we want to
see them battle until at the end and
that is exactly why we have the playoffs
also you can engage with us reach us on
social media
summer chess classic on twitter also
you're probably following this show
either on youtube or on twitch on twitch
both on twitch and youtube we do have a
promotion for every 75 dollars you
donate a player a young kid here in
saint louis will get a full semester of
chess coaching tell us a bit about that
alejandro well we have in the st louis
chess club a full
breath
of chess education we go all the way
from scholastic chess going from
underprivileged schools here in the
saint louis area all the way to the
elite of chess magnus carlos and fabiano
carona coming here for the singfield
club the us championship and through
that we do need to bring these players
up to space yeah and one of the great
programs that we have is that for every
75 as you mentioned we donate we'll be
able to
donate this to a chess talented kid
absolutely i'll be going here for chess
lessons with varus and coming with
yourself with myself so it really goes a
long way saying five dollars really goes
a long way here the same with chess club
and i encourage you to donate to our
cause it's a great opportunity for these
young talents as well as a great mission
of the saint louis uh chess club and
let's take a look at the pairings
alejandro we're going to start with
group a we have grisha alparin versus
jonas bier nicholas tiodaro versus sam
savion elia smearing who's coming off of
win a tremendous value
against sam savion with the black pieces
right now he will be facing the youngest
competitor in the event abhimanyu mishra
and new young yi versus aram hacobian
and
of course that has to be the thing of
the day this is it yeah there has to be
it around comes down from a topsy-turvy
event really on round three he had a
disaster but he bounced back
on round five a great win against jonas
beer puts him on 50 percent remember
that his round four uh game against ray
robinson doesn't count meanwhile he has
really had a great event uh he's on plus
two honestly could have been a plus
three if ray kept playing but uh he
could have been on plus one as well uh
honestly true taking into account the
first round and the game that he went
against yodori i mean that that one that
draw was actually very suspicious as
well so this is going to be a great game
yu yin yi playing for the victory of the
tournament i mean if he wins the
tournament today it is possible there's
a mathematical chance it's a
mathematical chance that he clinches
today so this is going to be absolutely
our game of the day absolutely and uh as
we see uh one of the players on the
screen right now we have aram hacobian
pondering his next move so let's take a
look at the position right away uh see
what's going on because it is a
relatively symmetrical position
in which after grandmaster i think you
immediately think one side has the
pressure and one side
it has to be white it has to be white
what is currently defining you can see
that there is more activity for the
white side in this position there's the
c file because there's a c file
a weakness
type of tricks
yeah they don't quite work right now so
let's show why it doesn't work right now
because it does attack the queen after
all right of course but you cannot take
on d5 because rook takes c8 exactly yes
and unfortunately for uh white there is
this refutation of just simply picking
up the c2 now you can take the queen
but i'm going to take this rook with a
check
king to h2 and i'm going to follow it up
with king take c7 which at the same time
not only that it captures a piece but
also defends the knight on d7 yeah this
actually doesn't work out for the white
pieces which is uh crucial and the
reason why aram can play this
but it still feels that white is the one
in pressure the bishop on d3 is better
than its corner powder on an a8 the part
on a6 is certainly weaker than its
counterpart on b2 absolutely uh my
original and again to remind the viewers
we are not analyzing this with an engine
we have actually no idea what the engine
says
but i feel white is just better in this
position it has to be now
as
we take a look at this one we have to
come up with a plan this is how you
approach this type of closed center
positions you have to find the right
plan
the way i see it is i'm trying to make
your attack on the b file from the y's
perspective obsolete and the way i can
do that is by placing this pawn
potentially either on b3 or on b4 if i
place it on b4 then i have to defend it
with the knight from a2 if i place it on
b3
then
all of my pieces or at least two of my
pieces are nicely protecting
that pawn and after that i can just
simply maneuver around the c file
because this is the key factor in this
position um at some point i would want
to play knight to e2 or knight way to
exchange one pair of rooks on the c file
and ask you questions of how are you
going to stop me from invading on the
8th rank
knight way 2 is my recommendation
on first class of course i mean i feel
like black is really relying on the fact
that knight d6 will somehow hold on to
his position yes because this is the
remaneuvering that he's trying to do
right i assume that in the past couple
of moves
actually it's been a while but somehow
black has played the move knight f6 to
e8 yes uh this is currently a
well known it's a hinge kind of
structure it has been a while it's been
a while right you would have thought
that by this point the knight will land
on d6 which is where it wants to go yeah
so all the way at move 17 and right now
we're at move 25. he played this move
knight to e8 queen to a4 b5 queen to b3
it's funny there's move queen a4
probably working in the move b5 yeah
yeah yeah just uh trying to create
another weakness in the position because
of course we know we see the c file
unfortunately both um of the players are
engaging in a conflict on the c file
nevertheless you have to find another
weakness in black's camp and this is
exactly what white is doing queen to b3
provoking b5 as you mentioned alejandro
now queen to a2
um why queen to a2 you might ask now i'm
looking at the move a4 of course right
and after b4 generally you respond with
the move knight to a2
why did he play this move queen to a2 is
uh quite puzzling
too actually now i understand okay so
bishop what he wants to do
is knight close to 85. knight to d today
it's such a devious move actually
you see it on the board and you're like
wait wait wait a minute what am i trying
to do yeah
uh so let's see how they continue to
look and this is probably what uh aram
thought as well like does he want to
repeat does he want to go back to b3
it's a funny position because neither
side has a clear plan exactly right
exactly and and he did find this
beautiful plan with knight d2 knight b3
knight a5 and we are in this position
right now now before we get into the
midst of the position let's take a look
at the b group as well alejandro we're
going to uh look at the pairings of the
b group in round number eight and
absolutely uh the most important thing
of course to remember is that brandon
jacobson unfortunately fell ill so he
will be forfeiting the rest of his games
jj alimorandi gets a full point which is
crucial for the standings as he is one
of the leaders uh tiger haritonian were
playing against christopher you nico
checko against camille dragon guillermo
which is one of the leaders as well
that's an important game against joe
jian ciao that probably would be the
right game of the day if we didn't have
the game of john burke against misha
antipa of both of those which are
surging players as you can see john
burke on your screen started not so well
with a minus one score in the first
three games bounced back beautifully
with the win on round four and a win
around seven meanwhile misha antipa with
a great win on round six and actually
saving a couple of positions here
he was completely lost in at least three
positions three games um but here we are
he's on plus one he's a contender for
the top spot so uh i have to give it to
him he's been holding on to his guns now
let's take a look at the game and see
exactly what's happening because this
one i have to say it's quite a tense
affair well let's take a look um
hard to say uh both players first of all
like the time situation
is worrisome uh you can see the uh
gembark has currently 18 minutes and
antipov has a little bit over 20 21
minutes and that would normally not be a
big deal but when you think about the
fact that it's move 22. 22 still 18
moves to go and and and that's the thing
a very tense battle any single
inaccuracy from either side is going to
cause them dearly yeah it's a very funny
position because uh
the structure really spouts out of this
was an anti-berlin
with the move d3
which is actually a joko piano
really yes yes it was a djoko piano it
started off as bishop to c4 c3
and then we got um
into this position and perhaps we can
see the analysis board as well
yeah i'm actually surprised about the
move already i just kind of uh give it a
look i really would have expected this
from an anti berlin because it is rare
that
white allows the spawn on d5 to go to d
all the way to d4 yeah in the italian
usually you take it on d5 absolutely
yeah he decided to uh allow that tension
which in return allowed black to play
this d4 try to weaken now the plan of
this move d4 is try to weaken the dark
squares because of course if white goes
c4 then you have some problems to
contend with bishop to b uh c5 coming to
b4 potentially exchanging the dark
square bishop and creating havoc on the
queen side now if you allow the pawn to
stay on d4 then at any point it is black
who has the option of taking on c3 and
opening up under his accord the d file
potentially creating some threats on the
pawn on d3 so that reminds me of the
game we played in san francisco
we played the game in san francisco i i
of course you don't remember i beat you
and there you go i don't remember it
i don't think we ever played in san
francisco we were playing this
everything we played in spanish i would
remember that
what this is fake news
and we play the spanish
we will investigate that we will
investigate that for sure
uh what tournament was it
the
is invitational ah yeah okay now i
regret it yeah
yeah yeah that tournament somehow
escaped my mind um so we have this move
g4
um yeah the the the
impression i get as a white house a very
strong idea on the king side
yeah i mean like g5 is going to come
very strongly yes even queen of three
rook g1 g5 would have prepared yeah with
some time what is black doing in the
meantime that's a very very good
question and i have to say
i've been looking let let's take it a
few moves back
look at the position that we have right
now on the board right
and
what has black done in the meantime
nothing
absolutely nothing this bishop to c5
queen to f8 f6
queen to f7 and white has improved
his position tremendously right now um i
don't want to say decisively because i
don't know what the assessment of the
position is nevertheless if i would have
to choose a side i would definitely go
for the white side
i don't think the black has any direct
counter player i agree with you just
because around the plans for white is
more obvious
i think that if you told me
look at the engine evaluation it's
probably like zero whatever
we're not looking at we're not looking
at the engine evaluation we're looking
at a practical point of view and if you
if you feel that g5 is going to come
with a huge threat
black is the one under pressure that
actually has to react to it somehow and
as you are mentioning alejandro you
don't have to hurry with g5 you can play
rook to g1 queen to f3 defend the knight
on f1 i have to say um i i do like john
burke's chances and i don't see and this
is what worries me um for antipov i
don't see his counter chances now
you would like to weaken the pawn on d3
potentially by exchanging the light
square i was actually wondering about
that could you even start
you can start with the pawn taking on c3
and then going bishop b3 yes you can
definitely do that the problem is once
you remove the bishop from v6 this
knight lives forever on f5 yeah because
h6 is weak yes you cannot play g6 the
pawn on h6 drops every single time um so
i will gladly exchange it and now i'm
going to hope
and probably i will checkmate you
you're gonna checkpoint
i'm definitely a very nice question
not not only that i'm checkmating you i
i i i it's gonna be very ugly because
the way i see it you take take and now
queen coming to h5 followed by g6 queen
to h7 if you do take on g5 however
i have the other knight coming if i want
to knight to f3 knight takes g5 i can
start with queen to h it's looking
horrendous right now um i i'm trying to
find a way okay
i think i found
a resource
i'm going to go bishop to f
the only idea in the position that i can
see for black
is to play the move g6 i i hate this
knight and the thing is that
g6 is actually kind of annoying move the
the knight on f5 is
the strongest part of my attack yes if i
don't get g5 in with my net on f5 i
don't really have one exactly and the
problem with moving the move h5 which
secures my network on f5 you don't
really want to take on f5 yourself
it doesn't allow me to break on g5 later
so it kind of stalls my attack yes
absolutely so uh bishop takes f5
probably at this point
now
you still have
knight to f3 coming to g6 on a long time
record not after queen inch fight in a
long time yeah so i have to prepare that
with the winter g4 get the queen out
first and then only and even once you
get the knight to g6 it doesn't actually
do much it doesn't do much so which is
one of those funny berlin positions
right where you expand on the king's
side and you actually make some uh
pseudo-threshing as a king on h7
doesn't necessarily mean that he's gonna
be afraid it's it's an interesting
position i have to say and uh this is uh
worthy of the game of the round for us
in in group b i have to say
absolutely supposed to move a though we
picked a good one um you want to go back
to group a yeah i'm moving okay let's go
um more oh by the way let's take a look
at this game between oparin and beer
because
before we uh came on alive it looked as
if aparin is breaking through and right
now things are getting a bit wild
because
guerra just played this move knight to
g6
i'm pre whoa what if i take it what if
that's that's worked very well
right rook takes c2 has to be the move
now the problem with rook takes e2 is
not only that you're going to take on g2
but you actually threaten checkmate
so let's continue the line let's say i
go gh king h8 and queen g6 the idea is
that you're protecting
uh the g2 square so like rook after rook
king g1 rook g2 does not come with check
very good point um
what do you play there after quincy says
i assume there's some points so there's
no other chuck outside of f2 and there's
rook e1 you can go rookie one and then
c4 but then i go king f2
yeah i don't see uh well you do take on
d4 but then i go keep g3 g3 and that's
the end right that's the end of it
because you don't have time to take on
e1 that's going to be a checkmate
uh that looks like it's over yeah
yes
so if you don't have that then
what do you do rook to f2 is going to be
met by king to g1 i don't see how this
helps here
this is such a huge threat all right and
by the way this is all
you know
knight g6 is played
knight to g6 is played now the question
is well you could take with the queen
because you want to do this though no
not really yeah
but how bad is it
how bad is it
not as bad as you would think right
exactly yeah uh it's not like well black
is losing immediately unless
this comes on the board followed by rook
to c7 but i don't know you go rookie
seven
it's not that easy
yeah this pawn on g6 was somehow easily
defended i think that you can think of
an immediate one but even take take rook
c5 or k7 i have to do so much counting
takes ray 4 rook c1 a3
or c1a2 this cannot be
seven
i don't think this it doesn't feel right
right no no no this cannot be winning
for for for white
um in the best case i think you're gonna
take the pawn on a2 and i'm going to
capture the pawn on d4 all right so do i
have any other options what if i just
defend my knight
i mean you are threatening uh
something thanks d2 right
so you want to start with rook that you
want the rookie one maybe rook c2
do you have to play queen a1 when a1 is
forced that's the only move right and
then i just move my king
king to f2
yeah
he's actually taken on g6 so i expect to
move queen e2 because rookie 2 i think
would determine was lost
he must have calculated something yeah
yeah
according to rookie 2. and i think he's
going to be played very very quickly
um queen takes it to queen takes it to
rook takes c2
what is
the follow-up
something tells me that this is not the
most precise way of playing this right
but let's say i think and then i go to
c5
i mean the thing is maybe this is enough
black is down
a lot of activity uh the king on f1 will
always escape perpetuals
pretty easily yeah yeah no i agree
and there's no way to set them up it's
not like a position where you play rk2
suddenly you're throwing checkmate
yeah no i i completely agree with
everything you're saying the problem is
um
i don't see exactly how to break through
if i just simply defend all of my pawns
like i'm going to lose this one i
understand you can't defend like d5 is
the thing about the director xd5 is fine
so you take on default yeah that's fine
now i'm going to go rook two
actually no i'm going to go a2 i'll go
right k3
a5 sure
a2
york ba7 now you have to go rook b87
and now i go here
and then we fight this uh exactly take
on it too you take on it
and then if you lose this one as well
without picking up the point but i don't
think i will
probably it's kind of difficult yeah
because i play rook f7 and then i put my
other rook on a7
you'll never get it
i'll i'll figure it out from there i
think
that's the thing you're one pawn
exchange away
from being an easy draw you're not going
you're not getting h7 come on
i i would probably win f6 for uh yeah
probably not probably not no i look i i
give white better chances this might be
a win this must be a winner i kind of
guarantee it you're guaranteed okay all
right i mean look i i trust uh oparin
that he found something
um
and he in general he stays quite
technical
uh especially in this type of winning
positions but with the material so
limited you know uh there's doubts at
times creeping it yeah of course i think
that maybe there was a cleaner way to do
it that's that's it does feel like it
right it it does feel like maybe he
shouldn't have allowed this queen uh
trade but okay well let him think uh on
that one try to figure out his way to a
victory now let's take a look at the
game between theodoru
and sam sevion who is coming off
a difficult loss yesterday i have to say
i mean this looks terrible for black
doesn't it looks very cramped for black
that is indeed
my assessment as well even if i just
take on b6 right yes i take on b6 and i
go like
h3 or h4 rook d2 just a normal move just
sound move
isn't white just like much better here
it it certainly feels that way
but this is the thing i don't think i
need to analyze this move by move
oh yeah i'll play rook d2 rook d2 yeah
just play it slowly play slow like f4
maybe king h2 maybe rook fd1
maybe h5 yeah depending on what you do
uh conceptually i have the pair of
bishops and i have a stronger center
because you're not going to get b5 in
yeah
potentially other you can go d5 whenever
you whenever i want right you don't have
to argue with that
so my question isn't quite just like
much disappearance oh for sure no i i
tend to
to agree with you on this one it just
feels like the two bishops now how are
we doing on time and this kind of
points to the fact that it was sam
savion who was struggling up to this
point because he only has 12 minutes and
49 seconds right now and his opponent
nico has 16 minutes and counting so
they're going straight towards that time
travel zone yeah unfortunately for sam
he was there yesterday as well yeah and
then he didn't fare well no no no and
they have 17 moves to go it's a lot of
moves he did not take by the way on b6
while we were discussing those options
which is funny because
it still obviously remains a wide
advantage pair of bishops better center
this is kind of a dream catalan oh yeah
yeah
and what do you even play with black you
have to play something like c6 that's a
very very and you know sometimes i get
this type of positions from a groomfield
perspective with the pawn on g6 yeah
which is better than this because the
bishop's on g7 at least you're attacking
something right right now there's no
tension against my pawns in the center
and we know that the modern type of
chess you get openings such as the
groomfield where you allow white to gain
the center but you attack it from afar
right right now there is no tension
you're not posing any questions in the
center my pawns are just
staying there occupying a lot of squares
and a lot of space i really like white
let's uh move on to
the battle of generations i will call
this one the one between ilya smirin and
abimanyu mishra
what do we think i mean it's white
playing for a win right materials even
but this pawn on e4 is definitely the
weaker one than uh
yeah if i get my king 33 you're
basically lost so
it really comes down to whether black
can prevent us so whatever happens here
it's a two result game uh miesha is
playing definitely for the draw uh
smearing i don't know what happened
feels like it was some kind of king's
indian i don't know how we got here
no it was a
it was actually an e4 c5 knight e2
i would not have guessed that in a
million years yeah yeah and in fact
that's not the game that we're looking
at um is that ilias miriam i thought
that's zhu zhong chow
uh i don't think that's silly as well
has a couple more white hairs yes that
that was my impression as well um it was
this 92 sicilian
and the strategy for ilia by the way it
was quite obvious from the beginning
take your young opponent out of the
opening
yeah these dragon type structures are
actually uh had they been worked out but
it was a while ago
atelier torzo actually did a lot of work
on this atelier yes
is right now uh
running for the gm title uh shout out to
atelia thurso he has this uh thing where
he runs every single day does there
yeah i think he's like on day
300 or something no no way he's running
every single day and it was
his mission to become a grand master i
didn't know this at all yeah yeah and
he's posting on twitter shout out to
atila torso go for him yeah yeah
yeah he actually did some work on the
dragon um which is why i was wondering
if this was somehow
some kind of a dragon position because
it did a lot a lot of work on the dragon
but also the side lesson of the dragon
the fiance dragon and the
11 fish dragon and all this kind of
nonsense the seven knights yeah yeah
early knight c6 with a6 yeah but uh this
one doesn't look particularly fun for
black i mean on a good day you survive
on a bad day you actually just get
killed and it's not the type of position
that you want to have against ilyas miri
no that is also another problem yeah you
you
you know what the funny thing is like
about these tournaments you actually do
see some of these players that's weaker
than others and yeah when you think
about benjamin glendora or union or like
someone like a parent right apart like a
candidate almost of course yeah yeah
it's a player that's fighting to be a
candidate
and then they're facing off against like
nicolas sedor or like elias miran who
are clearly not fighting to be
candidates right at least from a rating
perspective in perspective but you have
to understand that these are still
extremely strong players i mean elias
miriam has won so many opens he
clearly has a very deep understanding of
chess has been 2700 more than once yep
and he's kind of showing it you know uh
young abhimaan mishra is at a great
event
not had really any problems in his
tournament besides that game against
beer
which he miraculously drew but besides
that he's had a great event a very
strong showing but today i do feel that
he got bested oh
well
maybe not yet but he's definitely on the
defensive end
that ilya needed that confidence boost i
think yesterday i think so too yeah and
uh i like
ilya's chances let's take a look at the
last game the game that
in fact we started off the broadcast
with the one between you young yi
and hacobian and
a lot of things have happened and look
we started off after queen to e7 and i
said that you have to find a way to
release
this rook from the defense of the b2
pawn and this is exactly what he did to
open up the c file no he actually played
knight to a2 i like this move actually
followed by b3 yeah followed by b4 other
than a2 it was interesting it was the
control yeah and now knight to b3 it's
so that's
a very nice maneuver because the knight
on a5 did his job yeah it restricted
black's pieces now it's time to get it
to the better square the c5 square
bishop to c8
currently this is the position we have
what i'm looking at
it's 10 moves to go before the time
situation
changes and unfortunately for hacobian
he only has seven minutes and 35 seconds
it's not a lot of time
such a difficult position
that's pretty unpleasant because the
only way to really release the tension
is knight takes c5 and it's a move that
you dread to play oh yeah you just try
to play it
so
what is wrong with like knight d6 do you
actually take on a6 well it's white to
move right now because bishop to c8 was
the last move
um what if i just take on a6 with what
with the knight if you take with a
bishop unfortunately that doesn't work
because i do take on c5 and uh that
comes with the tempo yeah and you take
with the rook on a6 yes but what if i
think with the knight
that is a good question um it is a pawn
after all
it's not such a bad bond either it's
one of the best pawns right because
they're the b pawn yeah you have to take
because otherwise rook takes ca it's
because they take passer
take take rook to a8 is going to be met
by b5 but if you don't play rook a8 i
mean you have to play rook a b5 knight
d6 and hope that knight takes uh on b5
next move from something like b84 no but
knight b8 knight and ibn ab4 doesn't
really help you so knight d6 yes i like
this idea
but even here 67 roxy sex is also good
hanging on by a thread i have to say for
black yes if anything i'm not sure that
you're hanging on to anything here after
x6 to be honest yeah rook to c6 rook to
c7 is also an option
um
actually perhaps rook c7 does allow this
unpleasant tactic a little tactic that
uh black has in store
and even this even this they take take
and you have to still calculate but you
have to need three yes
you you're getting your own counter
chances um
bishop to c8 big moment right now you
can take a pawn as white will you take
it
or will he try to find
a quieter path towards an advantage
um
what do we think alejandro
oh by the way
and um what about this idea of just
simply playing queen to a5
yeah
that's also the thing yeah you can play
a slow you can play queen e3 you can
play queen a5 yeah 90 through 9. and
this is actually a big threat right now
because the bishop on c8 yeah i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna lie christian the
more i see this position the more you
hit it for black it's it's ugly it's
actually pretty ugly you know
it's ugly and i can guarantee you you
young right now is having a lot of fun
he's having a blast with with 20 minutes
yeah for 10 minutes to go and seven
minutes for his opponent yeah yeah i
think so
and he made the move he did not actually
he did take on a6 didn't he
i'm a little surprised about no he
played queen a3 a3 okay
perhaps the same idea right 90 well 94
just wins so he needs to defend against
that ah knight d6 seems like the right
move
you've been trying to get that knight
out of e8 for a very long time it's
finally time to do so
um and ah okay okay so now this is such
a crafty move
such a crafty move because now you can
go knight wave and rugby somebody had
bishop a6 and the queen is not on a5 so
that you can
uh pin it with rook to ace i love it i
love it it's tactical details that work
out for white queen on a3 is actually
better place than the queen 185 yeah
because of the lack of a pin so the k7
just absolutely gets destroyed
actually yeah just just yeah it loses so
the only thing that i can think of after
knight to a4 is what if you start off
with knight to b5 but then i can just
simply go queen to b2 you have too many
pieces under threat it's done this is
over it's over
what a move queen 2843
that that's why it's on olympic gold
medalist i mean you you and yi playing
amazing chess here queen a3 is a great
move
no uh i mean if you're a second c5
you're valuable
you might be forced at this point gross
you might be forced the only good thing
about taking on c5 right now is that you
have to take with the d point or not
with the b pawn because you think with
the b pawn i wrote p3 exactly yeah
very nice spot there um so you do have
to take either with the record that
being said if you think about a deep one
it's pretty winning yeah so rook to c6
and now i just have to find one b5 b5 is
it just got b5 tony will think about it
b4 right yeah so this will win somehow
i know you're very confident it doesn't
matter this will win somehow somehow it
will win somehow it will win
it it's also such a sad position because
the knight no longer has this yeah
the bishop whenever he goes either to b7
or d7 is going to be met by c6
and in the meantime i can just get ready
to
perhaps take the pawn on b5 with queen
to a5
um
yeah no it just looks great for for
white we'll leave it at that let's move
on just to check what's happening and as
you can see
on aram's face he's not very yeah he's
not very happy
he knows that knight takes c5 from a
practical perspective it's just lost
yeah but what else can you do game over
and yeah he doesn't have any other
options all right we'll leave these
players to think let's get back to the b
group game of the day the one between
john burke and michonne tipoff because
in fact a lot of things have happened
knight to f8 was played
where we left it off rook to g1 the plan
that we were discussing knight to g6
queen to f3
knight to f4
and now we have g5
and the players
did go into this variation quite quickly
take on f5 take on f5 and queen to d5
now at least
from black's perspective you're
exchanging the queens and
perhaps you're not going to get
checkmated because of that
um that's that's a good sign
on the other hand
the attack is still coming
against your key so what if i just take
on d5
what if i start with thinking on f6
actually
you want to take on f6 first oh
i'm just curious sure so let's say
let's say i take on here i take out what
i'll take on f3 first and then i'll take
on f6 then i'll take an f4 and then how
do you feel about this
rook just examine but you have to detect
this bishop
i'm not impressed by that bishop either
i think it's a very big liability i
still feel after the g6 i have
a bit of a pull i i
i agree with that i mean
just
white species are better placed white
species are more active right white
species actually have a job in the
position they have targets
they have targets exactly um
queen takes d5 is what john burke
decided to start with
and as we were discussing it does feel
like you're almost forced right now to
take back with the rook which is not
necessarily a move that you want to make
and he did now
why not with the knight which seems much
more natural because i can take take
rook to a g6 creating an immediate
threat and now we get this position the
same position we had previously but with
an extra option a deadly option i might
add yeah for white knight to g4
and that finishes the game that's a big
threat not only that but knight rook
takes h6 is a big threat as well which
might actually lead to some sort of a
checkmate soon yeah rook takes rook g1
you start a minute you start wondering
how black is ever going to survive this
right he's not he's not he's not
survivors so spoiler he's not
that's why he took on d5 with rook uh
and another concerning
factor for a young misha on t-pop is the
fact that he has six minutes and 23
seconds against 13 minutes
and still 12 moves to go
it's a lot of moves uh he's actually
just played the move
yeah rook takes d5 is on board
and i don't think we
currently have a move by john he's
definitely pondering his options trying
to find a way to break through
and that is another game this is a union
e against a copying game uh do you go c4
ever
ah difficult to say difficult to say it
kills your bishop on c2 but it is a
tempo
it is a tempo but
what else outside of that temple i do go
back to d7 maybe not that much
no no no
i think it's one of those moves that's
more tempting than it is good
right and i i understand what you want
to do with this movie c4 right because
when you take on f4 this rook coming to
f5 you don't want that exactly you don't
want this rook to activate when i take
on f4 and take it on f4 was crucial part
of the white's decisions that i don't
have four is very annoying it covers a
lot of important light squares which are
the main weaknesses of black's position
you want g6 axis you want e6 axis so you
want a lot of these chords to be weak
and you want to take on f4 but i don't
want to do it in a situation where the
rook on d5 is attacking f5 exactly that
was the thought process that uh john had
as well and instead of kicking the rook
with the move c4 he decided to kick it
with the move bishop to b3 which makes a
lot of sense because not only that
you're kicking the rook away you're also
activating probably your most passive
piece in the position the responsibility
okay
not only that you're activating it but i
have a feeling that this bishop is
coming
into the attack quite yeah what what can
you do you can i mean yeah what do you
have to play
but rook to d7 i don't know that this is
a weakness right now so i'm going to
take take take
you have to take you probably have to
take and i'll look to g6 how how do we
feel about this i feel like white is in
a great position
i mean he's actually played the movie d6
maybe yeah that's planning on that
because the recon d6 at least holds on
to the f6 uh pump for one move and
perhaps he wants to if you take on h6
take back with the king we don't know
whether that works uh or not we will
look at it in just a second it might be
if you do take on f6 take back with the
rook keep the pawn on g7
maybe this is the way he's trying to
defend this
visually
i'm feeling with the white pieces that
i'm one
target away
from putting you in a completely losing
position
i don't see it yet but i know what you
mean like a bishop gets three four and i
guess three four something's something
important is a good square and you have
so many weaknesses
right you've witnessed you worked in uh
e6 the g5 g6 e4
there's a lot of problems with your
position in general
and the only real compensation that you
have is an i don't have four and
maybe the possibility to take on c3
so we're gonna open up the default open
the d file so if this somehow goes away
i can imagine the white is completely
winning but yeah perhaps dynamically
black still
holds the shadows somehow somehow in the
game and by the way we do have uh a
result the game between vasquez and
finished in a draw and let's not forget
vasquez is one of the leaders going into
today's round but it's not enough he
remember that he actually needs to uh
win to catch up to jj he did not so
right now as we enter the championship
round it will be jj alimorandi who goes
on with half a point lead over his
nearest competitor and that is
guillermo vasquez he did win that game
by forfeit against brandon jacobson uh
that's going to put him on if i'm not
mistaken five and a half out of eight
and vasquez might be somewhere around
five out of eight uh quite a respectable
result now g takes h6 g takes h6 so we
were discussing the opportunity
potential to take
on h6 with the king he did not
took with the pawn and that creates a
weakness
and the king cut on oh man it looks so
scary right now
right but i mean black does have a
couple of uh threats uh somehow 1983 is
a real threat yes even though it looks
uh
loose
you can
actually you could stop him with rook g6
unfortunately that knight will pick up
the road he can't actually do that and
that's the thing you have to take on f4
first right yeah what do you think on
four and a second before you group g6
you don't have an immediate threat
knight e5 actually it looks extremely
annoying
uh
you cannot sacrifice as well like the
move rook g1 just does not work
no because the king nicely hides on g7
yeah don't go to h8 because this
beautiful bishop actually has a
tremendous task right now
but the blockading king on g7 in fact
just kills white's position
g takes h6
let's try to find the path forward
for john burke we we hyped his position
so much we do think that he's in a
tremendous shape right now uh but
where's the killing blow
how about bishop f7
yes
now you want to go here right
so you're saying that
if i do take and take and king and then
you're gonna actually
take advantage of the fact that your
rick is somehow an f8 and bishop it
takes a huge threat and i cannot defend
with this move because now
this pawn promotes promotes well
it costs you a piece but um that's more
than enough i mean basically i'm up the
exchange yes absolutely more than enough
yeah
um
that might be
bishop to f7
tremendous move indeed so let's try to
defend so you go to fate and now i go
king to h7 and by the way while we are
watching this game another game from the
b group has finished that is the game
between cheka and camille dragoon it
ended in a draw
what if i go king to h8 you're going to
continue isu right
i guess so yeah why not
the main question is why not right
finally i put a little bit of pressure
out there with the pawn yes and let's
pick up some pawns of my own oh never
mind but yeah good morning st louis
that knight
also goes backwards that's defended and
i was trying to figure out if you can
make knight takes d3 work but i couldn't
get rook takes e3 yeah well here i
thought bishop takes was pretty strong
bishop takes
take you have to take do i yeah
what else can you do like take here and
yeah
but then you you have king g3 at the end
also you have bishop to h2 yeah so i do
have to take indeed i take on d1
i would assume you take back i take and
he wrote this avenue look to d7 you're
going in you actually have a checkmating
thread yeah you have to go something to
e7 so if i go here just to showcase the
checkmate
that's every single piece is nicely
harmoniously working with each other to
deliver the checkmate um
so knight to e7 right
i think
so and how do we feel about this
position i feel it's dangerous for black
but how dangerous it's a different
question right because kg7 i could just
go back and then go h5 next move h5 h6
you're bringing another attacker into
the game it looks very bad for black
honestly
i mean i could think on c7 whenever i
feel like it and h5h6 is a very real
threat um
i can't be worse bishop d6 i just cannot
be horses white bishop d6 is a move uh
and a very good point you can definitely
not be worse with white
um
even though by the way i'm looking at
this position and even this
what if i go okay chad so you go h5 i go
to kj
i move no
d2 or whatever k2 h6 maybe
h6 i will take and and this was my
question
how bad is this
it just feels like i have some sort of a
blockade almost yeah it's very close
right this bishop on e5 would just hold
on to all the pawns yes
so yeah you might be right about that
maybe you have to be a little bit more
clever
uh going back up almost mm-hmm
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah this is uh much more of a problem
because you are more uh more zugswong do
you put it that way yeah yeah this is
definitely much more of an issue
no no it's not looking great uh for
misha antipov let's move back
because we are analyzing these games
quite extensively um let's move back to
the a group right now okay
and let's see by the way do we have any
more moves after queen to a3 in the game
of the round in group a the one between
you yang yi and aram hakobian
knight to d6 was played was that was
that actually the move
and knight to a4
the thing is like what's happening here
alejandro yes bishop are they following
no they're not following where are they
ah he played rook to c6 not bishop a6
but he did not take seven
why didn't he take
perhaps rook a7 and he just didn't like
this because
because of what
because stay stay stays knight b6 at the
end maybe
yeah it must be right what else could it
be
a knight to b6 and he's saying that he
actually doesn't have that much here
it might be true i mean you're taking on
a4 and queen a7
one on b4 is pretty weak
i'm not sure yeah yeah so he decided to
keep
the uh control of the position with the
move rook to c6 yeah b5 threat right b5
is a big threat opening up and creating
this pin on the a3fa diagonal uh rook to
a7 queen to b2 knight to f6 and knight
to c5 and we're down to aram's last
three minutes
and 12 minutes for you young yi now
do we have any media threats
i don't see any media there but it's
clear who's playing for a win right yeah
even the move queen a3 here looks
annoying yes queen a3 is definitely a
threat
but um what is black's thread do i have
something like bishop d7 coming
meanwhile we actually completely missed
this game but uh
they're harder to know than we missed
that game
who has had a really rough event so far
finally gets a full point win
yes he beats christopher you who
honestly also has not had a great great
event not a great event yeah
and yeah uh the last 10 or 15 games of
this i don't think christopher got any
victories either
i think only his uh
buy against brandon jacob yeah yeah and
did he even get that yeah he got that he
got that yesterday he got it right i
think so you're right yeah because uh i
think bran who is brandon playing as
tomorrow that's a good question i i
that's too much information uh needed
from the commentators at this hour
now
because let's take a look at the john
burke game uh jumbo against antipov has
actually exploded oh we were going
straight into the variation we discussed
right but the g um the chief has wide
open yes that's exactly what we talked
about and bishop g6 here we set king
rook to f8 yeah we started we we thought
about rook f8 because you could hold on
to the h6 pawn here like if you go down
that file
um
no but you cannot
oh yeah you cannot you cannot because of
g7 yeah sorry we've had we've had that
sorry sorry sorry so re7
this allows the extra check on g8 but
that doesn't do much
and then knight g4 doesn't actually win
anything probably not it takes e5
and i don't even have to do that right i
think i can uh
even though you do threaten today i do
there's a couple points right
95 this is a serious consideration
actually rook to g7
now you take let's say you take take
take take and we get this position
but you can take nick and bishop f2 so
correct
probably not better for white
yeah and uh by the way he did go from
bishop to g6 king to h8 immediately
responded and remember when it was john
that had three times as much time as
misha 15 minutes against five minutes
right now they're both of them
under five minutes soon to be
soon to be for john burke five minutes
and 15 seconds and counting five minutes
and four seconds for nishant
um
so he played his last moves quickly
quickly and that's important for the
actually for the position right yeah
it's only eight minutes and it's
incredibly complicated because even
though there are no immediate tactics
the change of the structure could be so
crucial right do you want to take on f4
do you want not take on f4
there's decisions at every corner the
decisions are tough so let's
see so how do we have the luxury of it i
think i would start with c4 i think i
would start with c4 only because you
never really want to take on
this move c4 i really don't know if you
want to take on d3 but what if i take
and then i go knight g4 i get it so if
you take let's see it's not possible
probably because knight takes f2 and
knight takes d1 but you do have this
extra move knight g4 i have an ig4 i was
kind of hoping that bishop h6 is such a
big threat that you would be
disillusioned in playing this
and it might be right i go back i mean
you could also take on b2 actually
take on b2 i mean it's the extremely
gracious move yeah
so extremely ambitious extremely greedy
but all right sometimes that's how chess
works let's go here let's
take c4 you can take another one i get
it now finally i get this pawn
you've been hyping this pawn on h6 quite
a lot so i trust you all the hundreds i
mean bishop f8 is the threat that's
that's a big threat
um
none of this would happen by the way
because i don't know man knight g4 was
played he did take on f4 first
what do we have here
what do we have here how
knight takes h6 is indeed coming
but at the same time what if i go this
move
let's move king to g7
defending
one of the ways of defending this pawn
on h6
yeah it's a pretty annoying position for
white because even though you have two
uh pieces on the g file that you think
you can make a great discovery with
not so clear right
because
once i put this knight on e5 i will have
all my pieces on the dark squares yeah
so good luck finding a discovery check
that does anything to me good luck
because it looks very scary but i don't
see a refutation no
i don't see a repetition at all he made
the move oh by the way
five are you kidding me wait wait wait
wait but we do have to understand why
not king to g the c doesn't matter let's
go h5 king to g7 let's go baby h5 h5 is
on the board if bishop h5 i assume rook
h7 wins question mark
h5 what a move yeah but rick h7 is
actually a huge move right because if
you move the bishop anywhere rook h4 you
have to play knight f2 which is
extremely sad
yeah this is and then anything right
knight e5 knight f3 or takes on bishop
f2
doesn't matter at this point
h5
did he miss this move good a bit what
happens if i go net h6 king g7 and where
is your knight going
that is the point i think
the knight doesn't have anywhere to go i
understand you have discovery checks
that's crazy
what a great
but do you have
okay so i don't see it check king h6
i think that's it because 95 comes next
move 95 covers everything yeah 95 would
be huge oh and he played knight-ish too
he did not even think of uh taking any
of
uh the routes we proposed nightwish to
the easy way out the only other way out
what if i take taken bishop takes f2
that's a very good question
so you take i take
take on f2 now it's starting to feel
like black is getting back into the game
at least right and he's actually taking
on c3
as if as expected and immediately
responded and take on f2 they're
following this variation
and they're going straight into the
second time control they're playing fast
now only four moves left yeah i don't
think rookie 2 rook f1 is a huge
difference maybe rockefeller can take on
f4
so rook to
okay let's
let's see let's let's wait for him
because i think he will make a decision
quite quickly and we have a lot of games
left right we do we do we do so um
in fact in fact this is the only game in
the big group yeah yeah
yeah because the harold union game
finished in a victory for white
but in the a group one game that
every game is going on the group
goodness
oh my god what is it check this one
this is the game between this must be
and uh
and this is over
i don't know how he took all the pawns
but this one is actually over right now
that he resigned he literally resigned
with a great victory he had a very
mediocre tournament there is no way
in the chats world that apart should
ever have minus one in one of these
tournaments he's such a strong player so
studio is so resourceful so strong
and getting to 50 it just feels
it feels like a little bit of the
tournament was rectified a bit of a
relief a little bit of relief for him as
well jonas bier definitely a strong
player
but opinion is a part and he really
showed his class today uh grinding beer
down
so beer is currently on fifty percent
ass is apparent absolutely absolutely um
and let's move on
to see what
is happening in the game between ilia
and mishra this one seems uh like still
ilia is trying to grind down the young
young mishra and he seems to be well on
his way to doing so because this bishop
to h3 followed by bishop to g2
and then that's going to force the king
to go to f5 will that be enough for
black to hold
is the question did he find
the blockade man that stuff i believe in
there like one tempo away from being
it's some sort of
some sort of uh
blockade but
we know players that don't believe in
blockades
libertarian fortresses different
fortresses yeah
but okay let's let's say that i maneuver
my bishop to g2 sure
and how do you defend i can get fighting
i got bishop e7
bishop
so i can give you a check yeah too
but now this is i can't even go no but
not before it's hanging
ah so b4 is segmenting before it's
hanging as well i have to defend okay
what if i
that's not a good move
yeah
that would be a nice uh finish to the uh
to the game
king twice and you're a loser yeah so
let's give a check
it really doesn't matter i just keep
moving my king king d1
perfect king to e1 and as we are
analyzing this we will be getting a
gregory oparin in just a second
to give us his first interview of
this tournament
he came here
no no no he hasn't been here before it's
incredible
his first time such a great player like
gregory apparent here in the studio
before yeah yeah no it's for the first
time and he uh actually told me
yesterday um i will see you tomorrow
in the interview booth yeah so confident
i like that confidence he indeed
delivered today
all right so as we are getting ready for
that one we're trying to understand
what's happening in this battle between
you young yi and
definitely the key game
of group a and it does feel like yu yang
is slowly slowly picking apart his
opponent knight wave 4 potentially will
come on the board followed by knight to
c5 it does seem like black is
extremely cramped right now but
while we wait for these players to
understand position assess it and
deliver their moves we do have uh
grigoriopar in in the studio with us
welcome to the studio gregory first time
uh here in round number eight alejandro
couldn't believe it how does it feel uh
to finally win your first game oh thank
you yeah it feels great
unfortunately it's a little bit too late
yeah i would prefer
coming here like after the first time
probably
but yeah i mean
i think i won a pretty nice game so i'm
happy with that
how did you approach today's game you're
playing against a player that we haven't
seen that often here in saint louis i
would assume this is the first time you
are meeting him over the chess board
how did you feel about him as a player
and what was the strategy that you
employed for this one
i basically just wanted to pray for any
questions right even taking strategic
risks uh
so my opening choice was like determined
by that mood so i went for
quite a risky line with a3
this uh
interesting idea early on in the nimsa
with a3 tell us a bit about this what
are the strategic risks that you are
mentioning well obviously
the the pawn structure white gets here
is
not ideal to put it
this way but at the same time like
white has a lot of points in the center
so
i mean there are three
just
many many ideas
and i was quite surprised by this ctxd4
i'm not even sure if i've looked at it
because like i i myself played d6 here
with black against twitter go
so that was probably my like
the main move i considered during my
preparation but even b6 instead of d6 is
like a valuable
like a valid move because for example
it's very hard to believe but after d5
knight a5 e5 where i can just point
knight it like
somehow like even here it's like almost
impossible to get anything before you
find you have some ideas of knight takes
c4 immediately yeah like you can go f4
with white but it's just absolutely
crazy yeah
someone like crazy line unbelievable but
black holes even here
uh was he surprised uh at this point in
the game did you feel like you surprised
him with this move a3
i'm not sure if he played ctekd4 very
confident quite quickly yeah
and d5 followed by d5 i think my
my airplay was very logical so i wasn't
very sure like what was here i did his
idea here knight to g8 and still he was
on one hour and 29 minutes so yes
he was playing fast but it
felt that
it's very easy to play for me actually
like b3 just develop
and
black still needs to prove something
yeah i do i did not like queen b6 at all
because just feels like work is wasting
too much time taking that pawn on a3
which is not that useful because like my
play is always on the on the king side
yeah
like and trying to get the pieces out
also it's kind of difficult for him to
finish his development without giving
you back the pawn
um which actually happened in the game
he played this move bishop five quite uh
quickly giving back the pawn
um
at this point i felt like i have a very
huge advantage
mostly because my own b7 is so active
i'm creating some direct threats
immediately
and
yeah maybe he has to go f6 because he
just couldn't find any other move for
him yep it does feel like after f6 his
king is just so weak
i always have some ideas against
against it
i just need to um pin the knight only
two basically bring the from h1 into the
game and yeah it will just be over i
think before is an important move
because i'm controlling the b8 square so
he cannot exchange
the rooks for example after bishop h6 i
think it wouldn't be so clear because he
can play our v8
and i might just not have enough
resources here
but yeah after bish before i you know
maybe he can hold somehow but just from
a practical point of view just very very
difficult exactly yeah with such a weak
king uh and your only counter chances
black probably will be tied to uh the
advancement of the a pawn but
unfortunately that's a bit slow um rook
to e8 rook to u1 and we got to do yeah
there was some funny stuff like if he
eat or coffee
uh like if he takes on d4 yeah like
take a pawn which is very risky but i
think bishop b1 just wins on this board
kind of
yeah that's nice so if you there may be
something else works as well but yeah
just just collapses coming completely
here you have to defend this bishop
queen comes to f6 yeah and it all comes
down to the weakness of the black king
which is just a consistent weakness
you're never getting better
bishop takes d3 came on the board and we
have this position
and
at this point
we got to this position this is where we
started looking at it actually yeah um
and we were considering
other moves such as potentially
defending the knight with rook to e1
but you just simply took on g6 yeah i
think i just calculated to the end like
that it's winning for me because i'm
just getting too connected points uh
because i'm always winning the f6 so you
saw that you're going to pick up the
pawn on f6 and
you are sure that even if you lose h7
with the two connected passers that's
going to be winning yeah even if like
somehow d5 pawn survives even even then
f and g would be completely winning yeah
yeah
i mean maybe something else was
completely winning instead of a takes g6
but this just seemed like a very
practical approach yeah no need to
calculate anything and just yeah very
easy to play and this pawn on h7 still
keeps the rook uh prisoner on the eighth
rank because anytime you move it the way
you're gonna get check made it so
yeah quite a smooth victory
one little trick in the end like instead
of dd7
like i wanted to play king g3
immediately
but then he can go rook h1
uh-huh let's say rook d3
rook h7 rook takes f6 or g8
king f2 h2 and somehow i'm using the
pawn you use the point and you actually
don't have a way to defend it yeah
that was a funny little light yeah this
is probably going to be a draw
with good play at least
yeah
well you dodged uh that bullet
definitely smoothly with the move rook
to d7 nice victory for you who do you
have in the last round uh benjamin
glitter is black
big event uh big game for you against a
pier in the collegiate scene as well
good luck we're looking forward to see
you tomorrow thank you
grigorio parin with his first victory of
the summer chess classic which puts him
at 50
going into the championship round
big victory for the young player from
the university of missouri and we still
have
a big game going on that one between you
young yi the leader of this event and
aram hacobian this is the game that we
have our eyes peeled on
uh because uh i have to say i i really
love
the way in which you young is pressuring
his uh young opponent yeah this looks
pretty terrible tactics don't work out
for the black side you would like to
think about the move rook takes p5 but
it doesn't actually work out because
after rook takes p5 uh you're actually
hitting the rook on b8 which means you
don't have to move queen take c6 yes uh
it's all kind of tactics it's important
tactics but they work out this allows
white to improve its position because
queen c4 is coming with such a strong
idea
quincy for org so let's discuss this
let's see what happens if i try to use
this pawn as a decoy and i think you
need to i think that's uh it's time yeah
yeah because as you were mentioning if
you don't get the queen to c4 and the
pawn is not already on a4 then you don't
have anymore anymore you don't have an
e4 yeah
now this is the move and by the way he
played it yes you have to play it yeah
you have to play a4 hope that you can
actually exchange the a pawn for
yeah for the b pawn yeah that's uh
that's the decoy that we are discussing
and for example just to
showcase the idea is that if you do go
queen takes a two rook takes b5 this is
kind of an ideal scenario for black
where even if you manage to somehow take
the pawn on e4 i have a feeling that
you're quite close to equality
equality is not what i would call but it
would be closer to a drop
you will be able to suffer for a long
time and make that draw yes yes yes
so
a4 on the board
i have to say um
i think it looked better a few moves ago
for white
something happened and the material got
a bit limited it really depends on the
following move right
if you don't have something creative
take the pawn on a for a while at the
same time preserving the pawn on b5
right because i have a move like queen
b2 for example but you do play a three
or four right you know using that as a
decoy and i don't see
yeah i don't see it either what if i
start with a move d5 out of curiosity d5
oh i see i don't care about the pawns i
care about the quality of the show let's
take it right let's take it queen b2
it is a check now
i just don't see a clear follow-up here
i feel i'm missing one rook from being
in a proper spot to sacrifice anything
right and this pawn is still dangerous
yeah the pawn on a3 is still coming and
simplifying i don't see it i don't quite
see it
um if are on the board right mm-hmm a4
is on the board black is very very close
to equalizing this one
yeah yeah and what the save that would
be for our rahm hakobian right
he's been under pressure tremendous
pressure i might have yeah for the whole
game um
big moment right now we'll see if you
young e managers come up with something
do we still have any games left in the b
group the big group only has one game
left one game okay it's the burke
against the type of game this game the
game of the round which has it keeps
heating up every time we look at it it's
it's change dynamics
oh so they just made time control yeah
let's move knight to c4 but
knight c4 taking advantage of the fact
that both d1 is pinned that e4 is
hanging and the knight is coming to e3
that's a great move but
uh isn't black just upper pawn black is
up a pawn yes a double pawn for that
matter but pawn is a part no not just a
pawn yeah it's a great pawn uh rook to
c1 what if i play knight e3 here
knight to e3 that forces the rook to
move to e2 something like that and i go
rook h7
to h7 i'm almost forcing you to go to
king g1 yes and then you go d7
you're trying to bring the other hook
and bring the other rook to the attack
oh man you're actually trying to check
i'm actually trying to check my new and
the the funny thing is
it's not so easy to prevent no
i mean this is a very this is a very
strong attack the requesting one is
pretty useless and it is opposite color
bishops which tends to favor the
initiative yes so let's go knight to
f i can even go rook g7 you probably
should go round three seven i don't i
think you're just lost so where's the
mate now for example what if i take here
now you just simply taking are you just
taking a bishop
oh this is such a sad position there
yeah it's useless it's completely
useless
so roxy one i'm what i'm 93 i'm i'm very
serious 93 rook you have to play
this might just be a very important
variation right now it just might be
over right
might just be over in
what an uh
what a sequence of important uh
victories for mission depot yeah those
would be with the black pieces
series of results drawing against
georgia and child from a minus seven
position and then winning yeah and then
winning again yeah i mean what what is
the use of results from depot who's
honestly had such a uh a disappointing
tournament oh yeah a player that
participated in the a group on the
spring classic was relegated to the b
group and now is making a bounce back
hell of a bounce back i have to say
christian because
it's not just
his rating and the tournament it's the
way the tournament was held yes you know
he was in so many problems in so many
games he survived all of them but that's
how it goes sometimes
some of these games you managed to
survive these miraculous positions and
then
the karma somehow works in your favor
yeah yeah
i always found that the winner of a
tournament is the one that gets lucky in
the first round
interesting that's uh
an interesting insight yes uh all right
so rook to c1
knight to e3 is the move that we are
expecting right now from michonne tipov
and
yeah that might just
show the game right by the way yeah i do
see an
a93 played and
dark piece on e3 so it is 93. i i mean i
have the
two okay okay okay so
he's trying to he's trying to escape but
okay you play rook h7 how did this help
you that's uh rook h7 run is knight g4
so you have to play
king j1
what else can you play forces
but rook d7 i think is just completely
winning so i understand why he put this
rook on between not on e2 potentially
he's
hoping that at some point he's going to
be able to get this king to e2
um
not that that's going to help tomorrow i
just don't see the move of the rook dd7
uh yeah rook g7 is coming with such a
strong move
yeah that's huge threat it looks over no
um
outside of knight to f1 to prepare this
uh but that one doesn't help you know f1
i just go to g7 that's the thing and
it's the same position same position you
take only three i'll be happy to go into
this kind of end game because bishop f2
is winning like it's just
you don't hold on no you just don't hold
on no like for example king f4 is not
playable no well it is
actually maybe this is the move
taking advantage of the fact that
there's no rookie yeah
then you go to h2 reinforcing that yeah
you can go to f3 because it goes right
g3 but now i go this move
and even here after take take rook g1 i
think you're lost yes i mean no i'm
trying to i'm trying to survive i'm
trying to to make to to see the next day
yeah
i get what you're saying that you're
you're barely holding holding on right
trying to see the light of uh
yeah
the next day rook the one king to f3 and
now
we still play yeah i i'm not forced to
resign immediately um
and this is why he put the recombina at
least you can understand why the rook is
on b2 another not yeah not e2
yeah uh
yeah i know it it does look one move
away from a victory for black
nevertheless
there is still a technical task at hand
um we're going to have to wait and see
whether misha antipo finds the right way
what do we still have in the a group
alejandro well the a-group is the fun
group today we already had a firing bid
against jonas biera an incredibly
important game for the stanx because
jonas was running away with it a little
bit over apart
terrible tournament jonas had a great
tournament it kind of
equalized things a little bit i agree uh
theodore is playing against stevie and
we actually should probably go to that
uh if i count
uh theodores have two pawns
no sorry one pawn
just one pawn but this doubled the yeah
i think that's why i counted it as two
uh but this looks over uh this part on
ace four is actually humongous oh yeah
right the a pawn is going to go down the
board
no this one might be
it might be a technical winning i still
need some working and some finagling but
uh
horrible hard for me to believe that
white is not just winning here because
you are up upon and it is a good pun
a very good point a great pawn
you don't even have a resource like rook
d2
uh would this be the first victory for
nico yeah nico hasn't won a game here
yet
but he hasn't lost too many either no he
only lost the pierre yeah in a way in a
great game actually this king after king
james
yeah yeah
he played c5 he's really trying to save
that pawn
uh very good c5 i mean
might as well try it
not only that it saves the pawn but also
it keeps some squares in check it it
does feel like knight c4 should be
winning right like knight c4 a5 just
pushed upon oh yeah yeah yeah that is a
very controlled bishop on g5 that is a
very controlled rook that will
eventually have to appear on the a file
to uh protect stop the to save the pawn
but the thing is
white doesn't need to put the rook
behind the pawn
the knight itself
defends perfectly fine
the pawn on a5 so if you do go right now
i can take advantage of that and try to
increase
invade on the on the d file and then
it's just a matter of time until white
actually makes enough progress to win
yeah this looks lost it it looks
completely busted but this would be
a huge result because that would be
savion's second loss in a row yeah
and this is the terrible moment
you could argue tamara in favor of the
yu yangyi
yeah yeah yeah yeah no that's uh
that's that's that's a big result also
it does feel like sam right now he's had
a tremendous
period in his career oh yeah this is
like the best
the best breakthrough from like 26 50
now 27 plus also
fighting hand to hand with the bastious
players on the planet we've seen him
battle it out with fabiano caruana he
beat westworld wesley he just beat
western american cup
right he's playing against the best
chess player he feels like he's on the
brink
of big things i agree
but now maybe he's returning to the mean
with two losses in a row and it's a
little bit of pressure right you get
that final breakthrough into the 2700
club and you really want to
make your mark you want to make sure
that you stay there for a consistent
amount of time yeah and this one is such
a setback for him he's losing i think 20
rating points even without this game oh
my goodness 20 rating points or minus
one only well he is the only 2700 of the
group
and there are a couple 2 500s in this
group right i'll be money yeah that's
like i'll be mine
right there right there i mean you lose
the cup losing boxes
that's like ten points yeah
you lose every every draw that he gets
to i guess the twenty six thirty two
twenty points is humongous right 20
points is is a ridiculous amount of
points i don't know if it's 20 but it's
between 10 and 20. yeah
with this loss we might be getting this
lost winning
even maybe surpassing 20 wow uh so
definitely a tough tournament for seven
who's such a talented player and you
definitely want to see him do well yeah
yeah but it's just not happening it's a
tough event and then this is
that's the thing with this type of event
what what did happen here where did
things go wrong because it feels like
the opening didn't really go well for
him well we lashed it off after this
move knight to e3 and we said that white
is just having a dominating position
yeah the opening just didn't go well for
him and since then theodore has really
proven
why he's such a dangerous player i mean
i think currently he has a reputation
for being a blitz player more than a
chess player yeah
uh but you know he's really trying to
turn this around uh he'll be playing the
olympia for greece
part of the greek olympic team is going
to be his first olympian yes it's going
to be his first olympia as well uh
actually a lot of these players are
playing their first olympian uh jj ali
miranda who's currently leading the big
group will also be playing his first
olympic he'll be representing uh turkey
oh so he got the uh he got selected he
got selected uh so
um
you know to brag a little bit the the
slew chess team is actually having a lot
of people
on the on the olympic team i believe
that uh we have
uh nicolas tidor representing greece um
to jelly mirandi obviously representing
turkey it's the roulette
we'll be representing greece uh gabriela
antova will be representing bulgaria yes
and i believe benjamin
uh bach will be representing
the netherlands yeah
that's five players that's a lot of
players there that's a lot of players
representing uh st louis university as
well as
their teams no that's an amazing roster
right there now
after f4 and this whole position just
seems like it's on the brink of collapse
and this is exactly what happened
i have to say i'm quite impressed with
the way uh teodoru as one of the lower
rated players in this event uh handled
himself against some of these players so
a great result for him this would be
uh this victory would be a tremendous
result for us to get there by the way
probably the the first 27 scalp in his
career oh actually his uh
um greatest reading win has been against
benjamin glendore
26.50 yeah this would be like way and
beyond way and beyond anything that uh
he's ever actually i think uh savion is
the highest rated player he's ever faced
oh wow yeah face uh 2700 plus for the
first time and uh take him down that's
the way to go young man now this one is
looking good for him let's go back just
for a second to this game between
smearing and mishra as we are getting
ready to sign off in a few minutes um
what do we think of this position
alejandro is he breaking through or no
is mishra
managing to save
another game
i wouldn't say like save in the sense
that he was lost and he saved it
it's possible that he just found a good
configuration to defend his draw
and he's going for it because i i don't
i don't feel that this is anything
obviously why it's better because you
have the better structure but how do you
make progress right bishop d2 does an
action card help you i can actually just
say
um
because your king is so controlled by
the points on c3 and the pawns on e4 but
maybe that's the way to go and then try
to play for c3 no no i just don't move
it ah you don't move i just don't move
it i put my king on
i just start i start running my king to
d4 okay so
let's make some moves because this is
because this last move bishop to e3 this
is his plan but no not necessarily okay
but like i got king e7 here sure
basically
i'll actually give you a check first i
don't care knd6
no
because now i go here you cannot do that
so you have to stay close to the pawns
in fact
i will go as far as saying that you
might have to go to f7 where your v6
but this might be lost right you take
take bishop d2 might be lost
oh yeah this is just lost i think it's
just lost right it was lost yeah once i
managed to exchange both uh bishops this
is winning because after take take i
will play c3 next one no matter what you
do
um and actually if you go king d5 i'm
going to go through
yeah yeah no actually the more i look at
the position with this move yeah
but okay i go bishop e6 and
i think that i don't have to be so
you're here now bishop to d2 no no i got
bishop 6 immediately let's go bishop
first move yeah first move
okay that's okay yeah we should go there
and i go check
on g4
on g4 yeah another king like i don't
know e6 or whatever sure i'll take i
think it's a draw
and here i go bishop f3 and i'm gonna
claim that you because of the
punk configuration
you actually cannot make progress which
is kind of uh kind of silly but kind of
funny
but i think it's true i i mean
get this bishop on f3 i see what you're
doing i see what you're doing i think
that's it right looks like a drone no no
no but i i don't believe you i don't
fully believe you i'll give you a check
okay
where do you go
i mean the first of all i'm going to
push my point and i don't think you are
i'm going to go in d6 you're gonna think
you're gonna take on g6 and i don't know
we're not gonna care i'm gonna king c5
taking king's king b4
and you don't actually have a plan
i do i'm gonna go g4 i'm gonna take with
the pump with the bishop
and i take this oh
that's my that's my plan
i know maybe it's a good plan yeah maybe
it's enough i don't know maybe
i could take with the h1 also right
you could take with the age pawn and
then it gets a bit crazy but then it
gets crazy because they
probably don't
probably crazy but crazy or probably
probably crazy winning yeah you're just
losing yeah yeah yeah yeah you do this i
i'm not even looking i agree with you i
go h6
and by the way bishop to d4 was played
as we are letting these players duke it
out let's take a look at the standings
and we're going to start off with
standings in group a we have the new
young e game of versus it's funny kobe
and still it's funny because i saw fire
be like almost last at some point in
this tournament uh we actually removed
ray robson unfortunately ray robson is
part of the tournament we shouldn't
remove him from the standings he is part
of the tournament even if he finishes
last uh
yu yang yi is currently on four points
he is pending his result we don't expect
him to lose we don't also expect him to
win thai uh we uh thought that was a
draw chain game gregor apparently has
won a great game again jonas very
exciting for the event i'm not really
sure why benjamin could do has been
doing oh benjamin glendora is being
given a zero because he's playing ray
rob ah right right right so he doesn't
get any points from that allowing other
people to potentially catch him i remind
you misha being one of them because manu
mishra is on three and a half points
playing his mirror and if he defends he
would surpass both beer and glidura and
actually oparin as well
uh getting to four points
uh sam simon is currently on three
around hucklebeard on three ilious
mirrors in two and a half and nicolas
sedora is playing actually a huge game
because if he wins this one against
savion he catapults himself all the way
from tithe tied eighth to guarantee type
third
it's such a such a tight it's such a
tight turning tournament it is really
funny because we have all kinds of round
robins and throughout the years i have
had the pleasure of experiencing all of
these round robins and i've seen all
kinds of things including uh spring
chess classics where i saw people get
one point or half a point out of nine
and then some people winning with seven
oh yeah and this is completely the
opposite we have two uh tournaments in
which the winner is gonna win with maybe
plus two on a great day plus three
it's not much
no
and actually the winner might be decided
today in the a group if you young he
manages
uh to take uh over at that game against
around here but something else needs to
happen right like you and you need to
win
and then admit
needs to lose but she's not
well we don't know yet we don't know
we're not
sure we might lose yeah
we're not 100 sure and uh indeed this
one is and by the way you and you has a
decisive advantage
it does have a decision i mean normally
we sign off right here but uh i want to
i want to take a couple of uh because i
cheated just in order to uh finish the
show
but queen takes a two apparently is
winning queen takes a two is all the
only move i mean this is not hard
retakes b5 and then this important move
queen a1 chuck
nice nice tickle yeah nice take on you
can't really go to the eighth rank
because pawn takes i guess
i mean that looks terrible one takes
yeah but then i go kh2 everything is
just lost
how is it wait oh wait
how is it lost take on f7
ah but you have king h7 here
oh man
this is uh this is some wild stuff right
now right but
yeah king h7 might but now i go knight
oh my goodness right takes on queen a7
right
this but b7 is not over it's not over
actually it's over it's over for white
for the wrong side um
wow what a line uh
wait what wow so
what is the move perhaps not take on e6
perhaps just
take on b5 first
you take back and now i go queen ah to
a8
no but you put it
now you guys
and i understand you have one check but
that's more or less
the whole thing that you have in the
position just check
um and after you take on e6 it does feel
like so we're never going to get this so
i'm going to cheat again you're going to
cheat again yeah
queen queen a1 king h7 is more accurate
than king g80 is king j to how many wins
takes takes rook a6 is one of them so
after take take rook a6 that means this
is just over because i'm throwing rocket
eight and i'm turning pawn take c try to
defend you just take the queen off it
just picks up everything too many pawns
too many points
so you have to go king h7 instead of
king j8
and somehow for some reason queen e5 is
the only but sufficiently winning game
makes a lot of sense
sure centralize the queen attack a pawn
why not also takes on e6 rook c7 is a
threat yeah
it's a great move
maybe it's a little bit difficult to
understand how powerful it is from uh
from hindsight a narrow path but it is a
narrow path towards v3
but there is a path there is a path and
it looks pretty over theodore's game
also looks over i mean it is such a
crushing position for uh for nicolas
yeah this is his chance
abhimanyu mishra is defending against
smearing
and in the big group we only have one
game left uh john burke is playing
against uh misha antipov but so let's
see what happened actually it was knight
it looks d1 did you see this move
knight to d1 that's kind of sick not
rook to h7 knight to d1 attacking the
people but by the way so many other
moves were like winning easily and then
he goes for and he goes for this one
crazy but it is also a winning move
because
rook 33 is coming ricky three is coming
and rick defier takes that fast also a
threat it does feel like he's getting
close to a victory uh
yeah michonne
which would be a great victory for him
because it opens up the tournament yeah
he's going to be half a point behind the
leaders yeah which is
which is jj yep yes jj ali marandi going
into the championship round
with half a point advantage and let's
take a look at uh the standings in group
b
ah there we go jj alimorando did win
let's go to court win his a round eight
against uh brandon jacobson because well
we unfortunately had to withdraw brandon
after he got ill five and a half points
for him guillermo vasquez with half a
point less is on five points camille
dragoon on for four and a half but the
important thing is whether misha and
thibaut can win his game uh get to five
points and actually pressure ali miranda
because it would set up a great matchup
on the last round and people are playing
against each other and tibop is playing
jj tomorrow which is uh why all of this
matters in in in a sense if antipov
doesn't win this game nothing matters
because i mean jj is so far ahead but if
antifa of winds he actually has a shot
at the tournament
well if he does make a draw then he's
forced to win to first play off but if
he wins then he actually has better
chances to just finish the tournament so
this is a huge result for the tournament
standings and meanwhile in the a group
if we have those
i do definitely have those uh we see
that right there gregory apart with a
huge win three and a half points blaine
german glendora did not lose the game he
actually gets zero points for playing
ray robson to remind the viewers ray
robson uh withdrew from the term because
of kovit before the half point mark so
the remaining games do not count for
standings
therefore benjamin lederer gets a zero
point by today against ray robson but uh
jonas beer actually loses to gregory
apart and might have a mashup of players
in three and a half points especially if
smearing wins i mean if smearing wins
and theodore wins we have
like the tournament 80 percent of the
tournament three and a half points
wow alejandro as uh we are
getting ready to close off the show your
final thoughts about today's round i
think today sets up tomorrow as great uh
of course we have always a chance to
have playoffs but today especially
opened up that chance apart in winning
uh misha barely holding theodore winning
uh yu yang yi potentially not finishing
off this game but you and you might
clinch the tournament today but in the b
group everything to play for jj uh
obviously gotta buy today but the fact
that vasquez keeps in touch
um
the fact that antipov wins with the
black pieces against burke makes the
tournament so much more exciting going
into tomorrow's route that i'm really
looking forward to tomorrow's broadcast
and don't forget that tomorrow's
broadcast guys it is early two hours
early tomorrow we do not start at 1 pm
the game starts at 11 a.m tomorrow
central time we start two and a half
hours after the round starts of 1 30 p.m
central time do not miss us as we go on
to the final round of the summer chess
classic 2022 love it a beautiful
championship round ahead of ourselves we
will see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited
you